Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday, and as you can tell from the gray speckled walls behind me,
in a stunning turn of events I have found myself
in an airport.
So, Hank, since Brotherhood 2.0 started in 2007, I have flown more than-
[Airport announcement system in background:] May I have your attention please.
Thank you for cooperating with the federal security required
[John:] Oh, no, it's my pleasure to cooperate with that federal security required.
My only request is that two minutes from now,
you let me know about the same requirement.
So, Hank, since Brotherhood 2.0 started in 2007, I have flown more than 400,000 miles
and as a result I have a lot of perks.
[Airport Announcer:] Smoking is prohibited
[John:] Oh, is smoking prohibited?
[Announcer]: at the Indianapolis International Airport
[John:] That's stunning. I would never have guessed it.
Like, I don't have to take off my shoes when I go through security because I've been pre-cleared by the TSA,
I get to board the plane first because I have a gold medallion . . . thing,
I can even go to the fancy airport lounge, although I don't, because it's extremely depressing in there.
But, Hank, by far the most important perk is that when the plague comes that is going to devastate humanity,
I will be among it's first victims.
'Cause that stuff never stars with people like, watching CSI at home. It starts in airports.
And I've always said, if there's gonna be some human-ending apocalyptic event, I wanna be
right out in front of it. Like my zombie apocalypse plan? Become a zombie as quickly as possible.
I don't wanna watch all the people I love slowly be overtaken by the undead.
Also, I usually get to sit in first class. So, most people think that the people who sit in first class are, like, rich
people who payed a lot of money for their tickets, and sometimes that's true, but most people who sit in first
class get to sit up there because they fly with the same airline all the time and the airline wants to, like,
thank them. Or, essentially, bribe them.
So listen up, infrequent flyers. As you're walking past the first class
people to your, like, middle seat, second to last row of the airplane, I want you to remember something.
You may think, "Man, those are the fancy people. Those are the people who've got it figured out."
But no, you, with your seat in the middle of the last row, you have it figured out!
Because, while it's true that I enjoy many
perks as a result of having spent more than 500 days in the last 6 years
in the company of the gray speckled walls,
there are also some disadvantages.
Hank, I remember once I was flying to, like, Dayton, Ohio,
and I sat next to a guy who had, like, not gold status or platinum status or diamond status,
but like, diamond-platinum-elite-silver-plus status,
like, he'd flown like 10 million miles, and I was so impressed, I was like, "Man, that is an awesome
status that you've got there!"
And he looked at me and he was like, "Yeah, y'know, it's a pretty amazing status, but
you know what it cost me? A marriage."
Now Hank I do realise that this is the first-worldliest of all first-world problems, like
"Wah wah, I have to go 30,000 feet into the air, and observe the majesty of Earth on a regular basis."
The thing about travelling all the time is, that while it's true that you get to be the first person to die
in like the rabbit plague or whatever, and that's huge, you also have to spend a lot of time away from your family.
And that sucks, which is why Hank I am so excited that this is my last trip to the gray speckled walls
until August when I go to VidCon.
Hank, I cannot tell you how excited I am to become an infrequent flyer.
I am going to make lots of videos and I am going to work on my new book.
But most importantly I am going to hang out with my family.
Which hopefully includes you and the Katherine, Hank.
But you've got to come her because as previously noted. I am not flying!
Hank, in the comments of my video from last week where I cooked dinner with Henry,
a lot of people were like, "You're such a great Dad!"
and I hope that I am a good Dad.
But if I am, it's not because I can like make some jokes
while holding a video camera and overcooking asparagus.
Hank when I was back at my child-
[Airport Announcer:] Ladies and Gentlemen of  (?) Airlines paging...
Why do people always have to get paged? I have never been paged.
I have spent 500 days in airports in the last six years and never once, have I needed to be paged.
Schermg, the light is changing.
I have to move because the risen Sun is too bright in my woozing eyes.
Ultimately Hank I think a big part of being a parent is being around.
So I'm going to try that out for a while. Why did- What is this? Wha- Why did no-one tell me about this?
I walked through the airport. What? How did this happen?
Has this been going on the entire video?
Great, now the people in the airport think that I am extra crazy
because in addition to holding a video camera in front of myself,
I've been half naked the entire time!
Oh my god, I have to go hide somewhere.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.